time to ask a serious question how did
any of this happen how did this happen
in the first place so i gave you a sort
of brief history of afghanistan and the
failures of all the administrations
prior
but let's talk for just one second
about joe biden so
joe biden is now blaming trump
he of course says well it's not my fault
that i decided to simply precipitously
withdraw they put out a pathetic picture
like over the weekend
this white house tweet they tweeted out
a picture of joe biden alone in the
situation room saying this morning the
president and vice president met with
their national security team and senior
officials to hear updates on the
drawdown of our civilian personnel in
afghanistan evacuations of siv
applicants and other afghan allies and
the ongoing security situation in kabul
well i mean if you took a picture i mean
as long as we know that's not a stock
photo or anything there's speculation
that was a stock photo by the way we
don't know if that's true or not the
speculation was because on the wall the
time difference between moscow and china
is apparently two hours when it should
be three
and the reason that it is two hours is
because before march is actually a two
hour time difference so people are
speculating that's not actually a photo
from like right now it doesn't really
matter very much bottom line is joe
biden is not present
okay according to the wall street
journal during the 2020 political
campaign biden presented himself as a
globe-trotting leader who at home the
senate foreign relations committee
served as barack obama's point man on a
complex international issues and who is
determined to bring a steady hand to
national security
yet the turmoil that is now engulfed in
afghanistan which has led biden to send
5 000 troops back to the country by the
way which by the way that's double the
number of troops that he was taking out
in april so remember that time we were
supposed to withdraw now we have 6 000
troops total into the country apparently
has confronted the white house with a
rather large
crisis biden said in a statement on
saturday one more year or five more
years of u.s military presence would not
would not have made a difference if the
afghan military cannot or will not hold
its own country an endless american
presence in the middle of another
country's civil conflict was not
acceptable to me well wait a second what
i'm question
it wasn't about us being present in the
middle of another country civil conflict
it was do we have the capacity to back
allies in killing terrorists or not that
we do all over the world by the way the
united states military is present in
over 100 countries
this apparently will not be one of them
even though it is now a chief terror
target
meanwhile by the way lincoln ramped up
the biden administration's effort to
deflect criticism saying that trump had
allowed the taliban threat to grow okay
so here's the question even assuming
that's true even assuming that trump
blew it with regard to the taliban you
came in and then just handed them the
country along with all of our allies who
will now be slaughtered along with all
of our resources because you decided to
precipitously pull out announce the date
and then just leave
and by the way it's even worse than that
joe biden wants to take a credit for
that he overruled everybody to do this
his own intelligence officials were
saying this is an idiotic idea his own
generals were saying this is moronic
i mean president biden said on saturday
he's going to be sending approximately 5
000 u.s troops to safely evacuate us and
allied personnel according to the wall
street journal a force slightly larger
than the 3 000 personnel were already in
transit back to afghanistan and the 1000
already there but this spectacular
failure stemmed from built-in flaws of
the afghan military compounded by
strategic blundering of the government
of afghan president ashkaf ghani
the taliban took advantage of u.s
sponsored peace talks to deceive kabul
about their intentions as they prepared
and executed a lightning offensive
here is that here's the key part you
ready here's how bad biden blew this
the afghan army fighting alongside
american troops was molded to match the
way the americans operate the us
military the world's most advanced
relies heavily on combining ground
operations with air power using aircraft
to resupply outposts strike targets
ferry the wounded and collect
reconnaissance and intelligence
in the wake of president biden's
withdrawal decision the us pulled its
air support intelligence and contractors
servicing afghanistan's planes and
helicopters that meant the afghan
military simply could not operate
anymore the same happened with another
failed american effort the south
vietnamese army in the 1970s said
retired lieutenant general daniel bulger
who commanded the u.s lead coalition's
mission to train afghan forces in 2011
to 2013. so just to reiterate the united
states worked with the afghan forces
they trained them in a certain type of
combat namely they could call american
airstrikes in they had the ability to
call in american air resources to clear
an area or to pick up the wounded and
then what did joe biden do he said we're
not doing any of that anymore so it's
not just a matter of air support
disappearing it's a matter of the entire
model was rooted in a particular level
of american support and without any
warning whatsoever biden just looked
through the support boom all the
supports are gone
okay that is like a house that exists in
the hollywood hills and the foundations
are not particularly stable
you could shore up
those foundations or theoretically you
could just dynamite them and then be
surprised when the house falls down joe
biden decided to dynamite the
foundations for whatever the security
strategy was here
there's always a tendency to use the
model you know which is your own model
so general bulger who now teaches
history at north carolina state
university when he builds an army like
that and it's meant to be a partner with
a sophisticated force like the americans
you can't pull the americans out all of
a sudden because then they lose the
day-to-day assistance they need
when u.s forces were still operating
here the afghan government sought to
maximize its presence through the
country's far-flung countryside
maintaining more than 200 bases in
outposts that could resupplied be
resupplied only by air there were no
resupplies available once the united
states removed its support extending
government operations to the more the
most of america of afghanistan's more
than 400 districts has long been the
main pillar of america's
counter-insurgency strategy
mr ghani had ample warning of the
american departure after the trump
administration signed a february 2020
agreement with the taliban calling on
u.s u.s forces and contractors to leave
by may 2021 but the afghan government
failed to adjust his military footprint
to match the new reality many officials
didn't believe that they would actually
leave
okay by the way joe biden was informed
of all of this he was told about all
this and then he just did it anyway
that's the part that's so so stunning
i mean
he he overruled his own advisors
there there were none of his advisors
told him that this was a good idea they
were all telling him it's a terrible
idea
they were telling him exactly what was
going to happen this wasn't an
intelligence failure as people people
are trying to blame this on the intel
community this is not intelligence
failure this is a political fail whereby
joe biden he did not care what happened
next period
that's the end of it
i mean how bad was this by the way how
bad did joe biden absolutely f these
people
how bad he did it it's so bad that
president biden refuses to allow
contractors to continue operating in the
country
there's no support he withdrew all of it
they are all gone
according to the daily beast in the last
few weeks afghanistan's air force became
a sticking point negotiations between
the biden administration and afghan
officials according to one person
familiar with the talks the country's
mostly us provided air fleet was
dependent on foreign contractors to
assist with maintenance
as the us withdrawal took hold the biden
administration refused to even allow
contractors into the country to service
the afghan military's aircraft
the united states effectively grounded
the afghan air force
so we took away our planes and we said
you can't use those anymore and the
afghan government said okay fine we'll
use ours can we at least borrow some of
your contractors so you know our
airplanes fly and this is like nope
you're on your own you're gonna have to
get muhammad over there the guy who's
hurting the sheep you're gonna have to
get him over here he's gonna have to fix
up the apache
and then they're surprised at what
happened
in the interim afghan air crews were
forced to get creative maintenance
personnel were relying on zoom calls
with american experts in order to figure
out how to maintain the aircraft left
behind by the americans i'm sure that
was going great i'm sure customers are
okay can you get a better angle you got
your zoom ready okay we're gonna take
out your laptop you're gonna aim it in
the general direction of the engine of
an apache attack helicopter and now i
need you to explain to me why it's not
working
gonna go fantastic
now is a mood issue photos posted to
social media show that taliban fighters
have captured u.s provided a29 super
takano light air attack aircraft and
md-530f helicopters
former british international development
secretary rory stewart told the bbc on
sunday everything is going wrong schools
are shutting down across the country
clinics are shutting down across the
country people are taking refuge in
their home looting is taking place
and of course
again everybody who
had the temerity to work with us is
going to be murdered that's that is the
likely next step here
now the good news is that again the
state department is making some very
strong statements here like some very
very strong statements in fact the state
department put out this particular
statement and is a stunning masterpiece
of just self-importance and delusion
quote given these deteriorating security
situations we support are working to
secure and call on all parties to
respect and facilitate the safe and
orderly departure of foreign nationals
and afghans who wish to leave the
country those in positions of power and
authority across afghanistan bear
responsibility and accountability for
the protection of human life and
property and for the immediate
restoration of security and civil order
afghans and international citizens who
wish to depart must be allowed to do so
roads airports and border crossings must
remain open and calm must be maintained
the afghan people deserve to live in
safety security and dignity we in the
international community stand ready to
assist them
stand ready to assist them you literally
just left you literally just left
okay this is a domestic argument where
the police officer arrives and the
husband is literally beating the wife to
death and the police officer takes one
look and goes you know what can't do
anything here he walks away but as he
walks away says lady if you need help
remember i'm only a 911 phone call away
that's what this is right now
that is so unbelievably delusional
so unbelievably delusional but by the
way the delusions don't stop there
we'll get to more delusional nonsense
from the states this is crazy i mean
it's absolutely not don't worry though
joe biden is not going to miss an
episode of matlock he has not spoken to
the american people over the weekend at
all
he wasn't planning to the taliban had a
press conference from the from the
headquarters of the afghan government
but joe biden that dude's playing
shuffleboard up at camp david he cannot
be bothered
we'll get some more in just one second i
mean this like you know how many
americans died to secure at least a base
a foothold for the united states to
target terror in this region
you know how many americans were wounded
in afghanistan tens of thousands of
americans
lost limbs were wounded suffer severe
psychological distress in order to
maintain a base of operations from which
we can kill terrorists we don't get
another 911. and this dumbass decides
you know what i'm pulling out i'm not
providing any support i'm gonna not even
allow contractors in there to fix their
airplanes
but how did this happen and by the way
it's nothing like saigon i mean just
nothing how could you even see a
similarity between this in saigon
unreal
we're in a battle for the culture and
for our values like and subscribe to
help keep our videos on the front line
of the fight and top of your feed